Hey dad, why do we have to stop here?
I just want to get on the plane.
Well, we have to "stop, screen, go" before we get on the plane.
This is a security checkpoint.
First, we stop here and hand our travel documents to the officer.
She screens it.
Thank you.
Then we go.
Wow!
That was easy.
What's next?
We stop.
Then we put our stuff in the bins and the machine screens it.
Then we go.
Do I need to take off my shoes too?
Nope.
Kids under 12 don't have to,...
...but your game system and Molly's bear need to take a ride.
Do we get our toys back?
Yup, you just need to walk through that rectangle first.
It's a metal detector.
Do we have to "stop, screen, go" here too?
Yep, you got it!
Stop, screen and go!
Are we all done?
Yup, that's what it takes to get ready for takeoff.